You know what's insane? You're literally
waiting for permission to have your own
fun. That's like asking your reflection
if you can smile. Listen, somewhere
between fingerpainting and tax returns,
you started believing fun required
authorization.
But here's the plot twist. You've been
your own principal this whole time. The
science is wild. Adults who maintain
playful behaviors have better
relationships, lower stress, faster
recovery. People in flow states are 500%
more productive. 500.
Remember when cardboard boxes were
spaceships?
That wasn't childish. That was you
before the world convinced you joy
needed sophistication.
So, here's your permission slip. Signed
by the universe, co-signed by science.
You are hereby authorized to have fun
without earning it first. Want to know
the backward secret to happiness? Watch
the full video to discover why
perfectionism is just fear in a fancy
outfit.